Your father is wasting away in the corner. Oh, Alzheimer's. I'm
dying.
>> Your wiggling avatar can save you from people seeing
your fat moon face, but it's not going to save you from people
hearing your high-pitched voice. >> And she just slapped
this fat kid, okay? And he fell to the ground and started
All right. So, if you guys remember, Nicholas De Oreo and Anisa
Joma had a dust-up maybe 2 weeks ago now. Let's start with the
Twitter versus stuff real quick. That'd be just a nice run-down
of the internet versus right internet versus now. Sorry, Connor.
Sorry. We go to the very end of this and it's Anisa just going
in on
Nicholas's appearance.
And Nick eventually had no real response. Nick's response was
basically like, "Oh, you you looked ugly before in the past."
He kind of got totally It was It was over. He got embarrassed.
And shockingly, okay, he's decided to change course. This is
where it all starts.
I'm a big fan of Nicholas De Oreo. What can I say? You do your
research.
>> Saying that Nicholas De Oreo does good research is so
funny.
I do Dono sound. That will be a new Dono sound tomorrow.
>> Legendary clip. What was the Hila Klein impression?
Listen, all right. In the time that we've we've seen Hila Klein
I mean, that just doesn't That's not like a tiered.
I don't know. Not only is that offensive, it's also bad. Like,
it's a bad impression. I said I had one. That's my That's my
Hila impression. So offensive. So so true, so offensive. Now,
believe it or not, he tried to come out and say that that was
a hypocrisy argument, which is pretty funny. Here's his response,
okay? Here's his response overall. >> they've been pumped
with salts and he needs a lymph lymphatic drainage stat. He looks
like he has a rotation of goods. Yeah, I got a rotation of goods
that are all beige in color. I guess that means foods. She had
the ability to edit this, I think. That's not my problem. Micronutrients
matter. Love your body. Take a multivitamin. So, it wasn't a
multivitamin. I just lost 100 lbs. That That kind of cleared
up the whole leg thing. But, I appreciate your courtesy. And
listen, all right. You could lose weight. You could regrow your
hair, you know? If you really Listen, I think around the time
this photo was taken, you were like a bald little boy, right?
Because you you got people sad It's just not going to work, man.
>> and shaved your head like Britney Spears. Wasn't that
what you were doing, Mrs. I Wish I Was Pretty? Well, I wish I
felt pretty. It wasn't I wish I was pretty. I wish I felt pretty.
Yeah, but I mean, the reality of the situation is you could lose
some weight. I need to lose some weight. I'm still a person of
calorie. And you can regrow your hair. I think it looks fine
now.
the tattoos
the tattoos Dude.
Hold on. Did I miss the part? Yeah.
Hold on. Edit this, I think. That's not He has a rotation of
goods. Yeah, I got a rotation of goods uh that
>> I did If you guys never watched the Big Bungie coverage
of this, okay?
I forgot that moment right there. I believe And I I will have
to quote Big Bungie because I would never say these things myself.
So, believe Big Bungie's like response to this was he laughed
and then he said,
Is this guy
what you were doing, Mrs. I Wish I Was Well, I wish I felt pretty.
It wasn't I wish He just starts going in on her appearance and
it's like, dude, why? Like, pick any other lane. Any other lane.
It's just embarrassing he tried to go back at her on her appearance.
It doesn't make any sense. >> I wish I felt pretty.
Cuz actually, I think Bungie's reaction here is like, "Man, Nicholas
feels so weak on this. Doesn't her dad have Alzheimer's? Why
isn't she going in on her Alzheimer's dad right now?"
>> It's like, Jesus, that's an escalation. And the reason
he's not going hard is cuz nothing he can say to Anisa that would
actually affect her is something that he can say in front of
his new like
highfalutin wine mom audience, okay? The new wine mom audience
are not fans of the old Nicholas De Oreo, okay? They're fans
of the new Nicholas De Oreo. They don't like the the old Nicholas
De Oreo. That guy was fat and creepy and weird.
They They hated that guy. The new Nicholas though, the one who
loves Ethan, who would never say that Hila Klein is a looks like
a horse or has a horse face or needs horse meds, that's their
favorite version, okay? That's their favorite version of Nicholas
De Oreo, okay? Yeah, we got the we got the Bungie moment. Okay.
How is he going to pull this back? Anisa Joma said he was fat.
She said his ankles look like they were pumped up with salt water
and he can't walk and he's and he's dysfunctional. Oh, no. How
is he going to respond to this one? >> Dude, look at these
ankles. Look like they've been pumped with salts and he needs
a lymph lymphatic drainage stat. He looks like he has a rotation
of goods. Yeah, I got a rotation of goods uh that Dude, what
is it What is this? That sounds like
Am I crazy or does that not sound like Jeffrey Epstein? Could
you not imagine Jeffrey Epstein saying, "Yeah, I got a rotation
of goods, kids?"
>> What do you What does that mean? Jeffrey Epstein.
Listen, I'm not brave or I'm not brave enough or creative enough
to make that leap, but Bungie is. So, thank God for him, okay?
W Bungie. That are all rotation of goods. Does that not sound
like Jeffrey Epstein would say
Does it not sound like Jeffrey Epstein would say rotation of
goods? I guess that means foods. She had the ability to edit
this, I think. You could lose weight. You could regrow your hair,
you know? If you really Listen, I think around the time this
photo was taken, you were like a bald little boy, right? Because
you you got people sad and shaved your head like Britney Spears.
Wasn't that what you were doing, Mrs. I Wish I Was Pretty? He's
pretty mad about this, actually. He's pretty He always He's quite
mad. Honestly, if I was in this [laughter] situation,
He's He's just totally seething, yeah. He's just seething like
transparently on the stream. >> The bald The baldness is
not The baldness is just not the move. You need to escalate,
right? You need to You just do need to escalate. You can't be
saying people sad baldness. That's just not going to happen.
It's not going to work for you. If I was in this situation, I'd
be bringing up a dad with Alzheimer's like immediately. There'd
be no >> holding back. Nick is in a position where he has
to hold back, but this is audience is like H3 guys. Yes. His
audience is H3 women. So, he has to hold back, you know? But,
if I was in this situation, there'd be no I'd be like, "Your
dad is dying of Alzheimer's. Your father is dying of Alzheimer's."
>> Your father is wasting away in the corner. Oh, Alzheimer's.
I'M DYING.
>> WHAT? I I That is not funny. I'm laughing because of
how sick it is. It's totally sick. And then I would just say
to Anisa Joma, I will attach a plastic piping tube into my arm.
And we will suck out the nutrients and the cholesterol and we
will pump it into your desiccated father's like near corpse form.
[laughter] I will pump him up a bit. We'll give him an extra
2 months of life. That's what I would say. >> Something
Something akin to that. And I'd say something about
And then I'd say something about the left. Jesus Christ, man.
Uh I'm going to like A lot of people would have missed that with
the accent and stuff. I'm just going to leave that one out, okay?
I wish I felt pretty. It wasn't I wish I was pretty. I wish I
felt pretty. Nicholas De Oreo doesn't have the balls to threaten
to
do what not even Sargon could, okay? All right. Anyway, that
was the That was just his reaction. That's a little bit of his
reaction. So, 2 nights ago, De Oreo decided that April
I'm not going to com We are in No iDubs April. Um I'm not going
to commit to not talking about iDubs for the rest of April. I'm
not saying definitively that I won't cover iDubs for like No
iDubs April is officially on because if all the content drops
off in 2 weeks and I've got nothing else to cover, I'm not going
to take a night off because I'll at that point have a mountain
of iDubs that I can cover whatever the [__] I want,
you know? Like, if I'm going to If there's nothing to cover in
2 weeks before the end of the month, I'm not nights off for it.
I have plenty of content to look at. But, I agree with him and
I'm probably not going to cover him unless there's literally
a drought
for the rest of the month. Surely Surely this has nothing to
do with just getting completely obliterated by Anisa Joma. Surely
not. Surely that couldn't be what it is. iDubs, Anisa, and that
was uh Keemstar Casino said that. And I think they're right.
I think they're 100% right. Oh, wait. Did Keemstar Casino say
something about Nick? iDubs, Anisa. Hold on. Hold on. Did they
say something about iDubs and Anisa?
for the rest of the month. Who? iDubs, Anisa, and that was uh
Keemstar Casino said that. And I think they're right. I think
they're 100% right. Oh, did they declare this done? Uh-oh. Dude,
Keemstar
just said they've got to make a quick stop off and totally obliterate
the Quartering's marriage and life and then they're on to H3,
okay? They just said They got to take out the Quartering's life,
his marriage, all all prospect for happiness. They basically
have to Israel the Quartering, okay? They're going to They're
going to Gaza the Quartering and then they're getting ready to
move on to H3, okay?
And I'm very excited for that. It's going to be good, all right?
It's going to be good. So, anyway, Nick's saying, "No, no, no.
We're not going to do this for April as best we can. No more
iDubs
And if you believe that that has nothing to do with Anisa destroying
him, well, you'd be you'd be maybe the only one. So, hold on.
Let me get this video
There it is. Here's this new video just dropped. He's coming
in. And she does a whole segment.
He does a whole segment here. 4:08.
Why is this not working? God damn it. For some reason, YouTube
timestamps are not working. There we go. There we go. 4:08. All
right.
Right here. So, she's going to go in on
De Oreo and some other people. I've not seen any of this yet.
So, first time reaction. I've not seen any of it. I'm very excited.
But, Anisa has been informed that it is No iDubs April coming
up, okay? I believe But she does brag again about totally owning
Nicholas DeOrio, okay? She completely crushes him again. I
um number one weiner boy. I just want to take a moment, okay?
I'm in a really good mood for many many many reasons. There aren't
very many Well, there's enough. I'm in a good mood for many reasons,
but one of the reasons why I'm in a really good mood is um I
finally was released from my um shackles in a in a sense where
I love my husband, but he cares a lot about people's feelings,
even uh ugly stupid people's feeling. Uh he has a lot of pity
for the Dude, there's no way she leads it this way.
This is crazy. for the slop tubers. And he didn't want me saying
he didn't want me bullying them cuz he's he was like, "No, the
If you're mean to them, they won't be able to handle that. Their
self-esteem probably sucks. They're already like really struggling.
We should iDubbbz feels a lot of pity for Nicholas DeOrio, specifically.
iDubbbz, of course, running in YouTube crowds, knowing what everybody
says about Nicholas behind his back, that he is like a total
pariah in YouTube crowds, that people don't like him at all.
So, iDubbbz knowing that is like, "Dude, you don't understand.
Don't go after Nicholas. He got his glasses stolen. He walked
around this party and embarrassed embarrassed himself. He's kind
of like saying slurs under his breath, but it didn't really stand
up business. It was very rough, okay? Just give him this one.
Let him make fun of us. Let him have one thing, Anisa." And Anisa's
like, "No."
No, we don't give anybody anything anymore, okay? They're going
to have to They're going to have to pry this milking out of my
cold dead hands, okay? No more. No more, she said. She walked
up on the playground. Nicholas DeOrio was bullying iDubbbz. iDubbbz
was taking it cuz he was like kind of I'll let this get out of
his way. And Nicholas DeOrio
didn't understand that Anisa's the older sister or mom the mom
wife, so to speak. And she just slapped this fat kid, okay? And
he fell on the ground and started crying. And there's suddenly
no more iDubbbz dark. It's gone. It's gone.
That's crazy. Wait, an aquarium? That is a terrarium. That is
for lizards. It's not an aquarium. Leave them alone. It's punching
down. Mhm, it might be a vivarium. There might be some water
down here. It is a vivarium, right? That's the bifurcated glass.
This glass is intended to handle the pressure of water. This
glass is just meant to be in the down. And Ian finally was like,
"Okay,
you can stream and I'm not going to tell you what to do. You
can do whatever you want." And I was mean to Nicholas DeOrio
for like 2 seconds and he and the other day I I saw a clip of
him in crying about how we're irrelevant and we need him for
clips and he's not Basically, [laughter] he's not going to cover
us anymore, all because I was like willing to say, "Bro, your
wiggling avatar can save you from people seeing your fat moon
face, but it's not going to save you from people hearing your
high-pitched voice. I win. Big
He called her She called him moon faced. Oh my god. save you
from people hearing your high-pitched voice. I win. Big Such
a babe.
>> She's going IN ON HIS VOICE NOW. WHAT THE [__]
DUDE. baby dude. Therapy is going really good [laughter] for
me. I just If you're going to do the avatar because you're insecure
about the way that you look, you should also take a critical
eye at
Whoa. Some people are totally fine with the way they look and
use an avatar.
Too far. Too far, Anisa.
Too far. going to do the baby dude. Therapy is going really >> That's
a joke. That's a joke. I just If you're going to do the avatar
because you're insecure about the way that you look, you should
also take a critical eye at your voice and the octave that it's
in and maybe consider a voice changer as well. But anyways, I
I'm sure
gender affirming care, a little testosterone, right? You're that
big for that long if it's with your hormones. You get just a
little bit of testosterone in that system, oh boy, you just wait,
Nicholas. He'll be a baritone in no time. Second puberty, just
like Pirate Software. >> talked because now my chat is
normal.
>> Like everybody is just normal people. We don't even
really have to moderate. And even if we did, like they come in
and they're like they're take a critical eye at your voice. I
I just But yeah, so I'm in a good mood.
Take a critical eye at your voice. Ah,
There's a dead air filter there, I think. Probably some pauses
cut out. >> because if we're >> Good times.
freak max. [laughter] I'm just 40. Uh freak neutral. Don't yuck
somebody's yum, but there's a limit. Yeah, yeah, and you're allowed
to have your limits. Also, I like some of you. Like some of the
freaks, you've come in here and you're normal enough and sweet.
I just some of you just get so weird. But it's it's stopped.
It's very strange. I I never thought I would see the day where
I I think it's stopping. I don't know. You just make fun of them
for being fat and ugly. Dude, she slapped Nicholas DeOrio so
hard that like a bunch of Keemstar Casino viewers became fans
of
That's crazy.
That's That's insane, man. E uh and you can only address that
so much, lol. Half our audience cranked it to her at least once.
Uh that's a very conservative estimate, Nemo, but thank you for
the the unbridled misogyny. Kind of a weird comment. I'd keep
it to just that. I will say obviously conservative estimate.
Obviously, you're aiming low
Oh, there's nothing uh on go back and forth. Yeah, because I
win. Because I'm neither of those things. And I have great hip
mobility, which he also can't say. And I have a deeper voice
than him, more muscle mass, smarter, I'm quicker >> Dude,
what the [__]
What is she doing?
He already gave up. He already gave up, Anisa. He's dead. Anisa,
stop punching him. She just knocked Nicholas out in the octagon,
okay? And the ref like pulled her off and she jumped back down
and just kept throwing hammer fists into this guy's skull over
and over and over again. That's crazy. >> only address
that so much, lol. There's nothing uh on go back and forth. Yeah,
because I win. Because I'm neither of those things. And I have
great hip mobility, which he also can't say. And I have a deeper
voice than him, more muscle mass, smarter, I'm quicker physically
and mentally. I think I'm more entertaining. He better hope I
don't go for his wig and take his whole job. But his viewer count's
already dropping because girl bun and and big fat bacon face.
>> Sorry, I didn't think that. Harley's not fat. He's athletic.
But uh greasy bacon face and girl with a bun are taking his uh
viewership. So, I don't have to do anything. [screaming]
You can't your lunch taken by Glam
and Harley. Oh my god. I don't get the hip mobility one. I do
believe that Is that a joke about her
Hey, I actually I mean, also technically ligaments and muscle
wise, obviously she'd have more hip mobility, but
you know, it is what it is. >> thing. Do nothing win. I
mog him by just existing. Sucks to suck. Bacon and egg. You're
a little bit taller, more baller, has a girl
uh who looks good. You should call her. That's true. That's all
true. I actually do think I am taller than Nicholas
Or there his knees don't bend.
That's true. He That's true. I guess that is hip mobility technically
to swing your legs requires like hip mobility. And so he like
lifts one side of his body and pivots, right?
Uses his his foot that's on the ground still as a pivot point
so that he can move. Really [__] up. He thought I
was being fat phobic when I was calling him a toad with arms,
but I was more referring to his ratio of leg to uh torso to arm.
Like I don't think he's that tall. He looks like he's maybe He
might be wider than he is tall. Maybe not now. I think he's on
Ozempic, but still ugly. I do think I am taller than
On Ozempic? What?
Nicholas got some Zempic? That's crazy.
Bro, when when will she stop? She This guy was dead like eight
catty comments ago and she just keeps going over and over. Um
He's actually like a toad with arms. I said he was like a toad
with arms. They said that was fat phobic. I just think it's descriptive.
>> No. So, anyways, that's why I'm in a good mood. Ozempic?
I mean, I don't know. Maybe he's not on Ozempic. He lost some
weight. I always just assume Ozempic. Anybody who's connected
to Ethan Klein, I just assume it's Ozempic. They They got the
hookup, you know? Oh, grunge fit is slay today. Thank you.
Uh do you have a favorite quick childhood food? Oh my god, I
do. Uh it's been a while. Frozen waffles with peanut butter.
I loved Eggo waffles with syrup, but I and I wish Ian wasn't
a celiac because toasting bread and then Yeah, I can't eat as
an adult,
but I'm not joking.
I used to do
uh like Eggo waffles, like the cheap Eggo waffles,
with Cheez Whiz.
You guys put Cheez Whiz on things when you're a kid? I didn't
realize that I was like kind of poor growing up and that like
we had Cheez Whiz on a lot of stuff cuz we were poor.
And so I thought Cheez Whiz was awesome when I was a kid. And
then all my friends when I got to university and I like like
Cheez Whiz on toast, they all like hated me. They're all like,
"How do you eat that? That's garbage." I'm like, "Dude, I don't
know. I just have like baloney sandwiches and Cheez Whiz when
I was a kid. I didn't realize it just
I don't know. For breakfast, it was like cheaper stuff.
I don't know. I felt I was My family was rich in love, okay?
We were rich in
No, um that was like a for a while that happened, but I I don't
think we were actually poor. I think my my grandmother was who
like did this stuff. And we had money cuz we had we'd buy like
full and half-sides of beef for like the family.
We had money. It was just that
for some reason my grandparents like rationed money and food
and stuff as if they were going to be poor and and like destitute
at any point. Is that like the plasticky cheese? Yeah, it is.
I can already tell I'm not even listening to chat. I can already
tell you guys are all totally grossed out by
But my grandparents grew up on a farm, so they all like they
all went through times where food was actually tight. And so
they just basically yeah, it's immigrant mindset. Unironically
immigrant farmer mindset of like we're going to run out of food
again someday and so we stockpile all of this stuff. What will
last forever? Cheese whiz. That's what will last forever. Mixing
Were they in Europe for the war? I mean my great-grandparents
almost certainly would have been in Europe for the war. Came
from Ukraine.
So definitely Ukraine and parts of Poland in some cases. >> Girl,
cinnamon and butter. It's so good. If you lost weight after 2024
Ozempic. I often What it is for me, I'm going to be honest with
you. >> My eggs are dwindling. What it is for me when I
assume [laughter] it's Ozempic, it's typically when somebody
loses a bunch of weight and has no muscle mass or change in face.
Especially no muscle mass because a lot of people use Ozempic
as like a suppressant, but they don't work out. So it becomes
very obvious. Like if you look at Ethan Klein's legs, like that
is so glaringly obviously like Ozempic in my opinion. In my opinion,
Ozempic in my opinion. As a big girl enjoyer, Ozempic has devastated
the community. [laughter]
So Clock Twenty said he can't
All right. I think that's it for the Anisa clip. Oh, no, sorry,
that's not. The this continues for a long time. Oh, Do we have
like 10 more minutes of this? Holy sh
We've got four and a half more minutes of this. >> I actually
do think he can't curl 20 lbs. I do I do mean that one. And I
Will we get a response from Nicholas? Will Nicholas respond?
Can you curl 20 lbs, Nick?
You guys think Nick can curl Is this why he actually left? This
says March 29th. Did he leave because he was terrified
to be asked to prove that he could curl 20 lbs?
Those little itty-bitty 10-lb dumbbells? He cannot do that. >> of
wanted to see cuz there was that one time that I baited him into
measuring himself. I I will say I think Ethan Klein is taller
than Nicholas Deorio. I Nicholas Deorio gives 5 ft 4 energy.
I think Ethan is a little taller than me. Like I actually think
Ethan's like maybe 5 7. I'm 5 6 and 1/2, so I'll give him 5 7.
But I I did like that I got him to to measure himself live on
stream.
And so I was hoping that if I asked him to curl weight, I wanted
to see I want to see if he would do it. He would fail. I'm I'm
like 90% sure, but us bears are also really hurting from the
GLP-1
That wouldn't wouldn't you be fine if you were a bear and the
GLP stuff wouldn't that increase your market value? curl weight,
I wanted to see I want to see if he would do it. He would fail.
I'm I'm like 90% sure, but us bears are also really hurting from
the GLP-1 craze. Oh my god, that's so sad. I spat out my coffee
when I heard your Ethan impression for the first time. I got
so many compliments on that like in the DMs from people that
I was not expecting. Yeah, he tried to rip a shirt after you
called him out. He couldn't [laughter] even do that. I his Oh,
I forgot that Ethan Klein tried to rip that shirt and totally
failed and then looked like a That was like right before he did
the posture thing, right? And then he was like coping on stream
about how his posture wasn't that bad and it is just a still
frame from the thing. Oh, and then Anisa and iDubbz tried to
recreate it and they eventually were able to recreate it, okay.
>> His grip strength might be worse than his curling ability.
The fact a couple days after you made that comment, he couldn't
even rip [laughter] up a shirt. Oh, no.
As somebody who works out and still struggles with weight, I
get wanting to try Ozempic or something similar.
Dude, the funniest thing is is the more she laughs at this kind
of stuff with regards to Ethan Klein, do you think do you think
the Kino Casino guys aren't going to see this stuff and start
to realize what a lolcow Ethan Klein is?
Could you imagine if they really turned their lens towards Ethan
Klein?
And trust me, here's the best argument for them, okay? PPP, Andy
Warski, hear me now. If you guys want to snark on the
a thousand people will materialize out of nowhere. It'll be nothing
for you, okay? You literally won't have to work for weeks. They'll
materialize and they will lay out dockets for you. They will
give you every single thing you need. It's the freest like month
of money you could ever make. Just saying, if you wanted some
enticement cuz I know I didn't I didn't get into disliking Ethan
Klein for that reason, but trust me, if you go, "Hey, does this
Ethan Klein clip exist?" People materialize to go, "Yes, it does.
Yes, here's here's this clip and eight other related clips."
So I got into it naturally and organically, but if you do ever
get into it, they these people materialize out of nowhere, okay?
Like magicians. You I want to like be very clear. There is absolutely
nothing wrong with using Ozempic if you're using it properly
and responsibly. There are a ton of people who do have legitimate
problems losing weight and they are working out and they are
eating healthy and they need GLP-1s to get them over the hump,
right? They're This is not true. This is like kind kind of just
cope. This is not true at all. But I will say that like if you
had to take some kind of medication,
if that's going to help you get into the habit of like exercising
or eating better, those habits are hard to form in a vacuum.
And so if those if those medicines get you over the hump in changing
the habits,
totally go for it, right? But this her saying like well, some
people eat well and exercise and they still can't No, they don't.
That does That person doesn't exist. That person has never existed.
Come on.
But if you need help getting those those actual habits formed,
it's smart to do. You should do that.
You should do it for sure. >> absolutely like obesity is
a very complex issue. And I don't >> Like Like if you're
the size that Nick was, like if you're that big, it's probably
hard to even go for walks, right? It's hard to build the muscle
while you're losing weight. And so to start losing some weight,
it Like I I do believe every single person who gets like that
size should start taking I don't know, some kind of like possibly
a low-dose amphetamine to some kind, some appetite suppressant
or, you know, Ozempic GLP-1s if that's what
Cuz it like it Don't [__] up your joints, right?
You should lose some weight before you try to get into like running
or something. >> think anybody should be shamed for needing
GLP-1s. I shame people for abusing GLP-1s.
It's the abusing the GLP-1s and not respecting your body, right?
It's It's you're not respecting your body. When you look at Ethan
Klein's legs, that's not respect your body. You're not You're
not eating properly, clearly. You're not It looks like he hasn't
gone up a flight of stairs in like, I don't know, maybe a
It's It's in my opinion very pathetic. And yeah, I don't know.
It's just To me it also screams
This is going to be like a maybe like a too complicated for the
room take, but somebody who uses Ozempic in the way that in my
opinion in my opinion in my opinion. The way that Ethan Klein
seems to be using Ozempic in my opinion is
it's it's fat phobic in nature because it seems like the only
thing he cares about is how skinny he is rather than any like
health related This is such a weird cope about Ethan. What the
hell?
Not even cope. It's just like a weird
It's a weird theory to pursue. That's all. It's fat phobic because
he's willing to destroy his body just to not be fat. I mean,
I guess.
Maybe I'm Maybe I'm judging you too harshly. Hold on. I'll pull
it back. Maybe I'm judging you too harshly. >> Ethan Klein
seems to be using Ozempic in my opinion is
it's it's fat phobic in nature because it seems like the only
thing he cares about is how skinny he is rather than any like
health related benefits that come with GLP-1s. So that's my take
on it. And that's why I make fun of him for it. I don't think
people using GLP-1s in general should be made fun
for it, but he deserves it. And not because of solely the GLP-1
use. I'm trying to like cover my bases cuz I know it's going
to get clipped. It's Somebody's going to be like, "She She said
that he's using GLP-1s and all people WHO ARE FAT ARE pieces
of shit." I'm not. Yeah, his wife's constant fat shaming doesn't
help. Yeah. And again, I will clarify there are many many many
many many many beautiful fat people, okay? Nicholas Deorio is
not one and Ethan Klein while using Ozempic is not one, either.
thought I heard the whole world say, "Leave her E and leave her."
>> Dude, this is like a This is like an Anisa Alog channel,
but it has turned into like an Anisa highlights channel. Man,
making fun of someone's weight, someone's height, how they sound.
Man, not very empathetic of her. Yeah?
Dude, this is like an actual Anisa Alog channel that just gives
us awesome Anisa highlights all the time. It's actually cool.
Anisa wants to make sure Nick watches a whole clip of hers instead
of cutting it off halfway.
Nicholas Deorio, that's the guy that called out Ian and Anisa's
charity boxing event that made $0 for charity. Remember Creator
Clash? I remember. You can tell this is a Nicholas Deorio fan.
That's literally the way he does
Guys, remember this random little thing that happened once? I
remember. You remember the time Bo Burnham was a woman? I remember.
You remember the time You remember the time that John Swan was
a weirdo with the allegations? I
Every time, okay? time All right. What's I think that's it for
the next segment. I think we're done with that one. I think so.
I think so.